when you go home tonight you see your
friend you see your wife can you explain
the one in three seconds those guys they
are the guys mixing liquids and
mechanics my name is Vincent Payard i'm
the CEO of hyt we have been trying for
the last 300 years to avoid liquid
inside the watch and here we are in a
working with as a friend with the liquid
we use the liquid to display at a time
far as the innovation is the key thing
in fact hyt is based on innovation when
we created the watch we didn't want to
just to create another watch you know
just to come with with another around
wash with the hands thank you it's all
about the design and the marketing
behind here the innovation is the key
driver it is all about the innovation
mixing liquids and mechanics right now
it's nine-thirty the liquid is between
nine and 10 and the hand here indicates
the minutes if i continue i can move by
rick my liquid so ours by the liquid and
the minutes in the center with the
analogic hand now if i go from New York
to Los Angeles I go backwards see my
liquid is going backwards we have
something which is easy to understand
the to accomplish it to make it happen
is like three years of work and it's a
huge effort of chemistry and mechanics
and engineering to make it happen